good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Monday hope everyone's
having a fabulous gorgeous stunning
beautiful stunning Spa weekly talented
beginning of their week speaking of
wickedly talented it's a girl that I
know that I love it's Jackie oh hey
Jack's hater I'm doing good would you
say that I'm wickedly talented I thought
that's where you were going
did I not say that I don't know I
thought you were about to like speaking
of Wiki wickedly talented it's a girl
that I know
I don't know if so I guess I didn't
actually say it but I didn't mean to
call you wickedly talented thank you so
much that's what I was bracing for and I
was so flattered because
I think what we do here is truly a
talent special and I find you to be so
talented in the craft so it's like it
means a lot coming from you that's so
sweet like you calling me talented me
calling you talented like we're in such
a good mood today it's fabulous fabulous
we're so positive considering I know the
events of yesterday yeah
yeah
yeah so let's talk about it let's let's
talk about it I think we should start
let's start at the beginning of the
weekend because we haven't been together
on air since Thursday right Friday was
our Jay Shetty episode
um the reviews are in I mean people are
obsessed I think a lot of people who
love Jay like obviously he's a huge
podcast he's like 12 million followers
they were so excited and then a lot of
people that were doubtful they're like
who's this Jay Shetty I thought it was
going to be Taylor Swift so where are
you saying they're doubters
non-believers that's exactly what I was
saying thank you for putting it to a
tune like that
um
and so many hearts and Minds were
changed I knew people were going to be
obsessed with the episode like you know
when you're doing something and you know
it's good sometimes you're doing
something you know it's [__] but I knew
what I was doing was good and I'm so
people were loving it I know so many
people pre-ordered his book so I think
Jay had a fabulous time Jay sent me a
voice memo
um he was like I'm reading through the
comments on like YouTube and like your
fans are so nice and like they're all
ordering the book and I just really
appreciate you having me on and you know
I'm he was just he was blown away by the
power of the toast and I was so proud to
be like head toaster you know that's
such a prideful moment it was and so I'm
so glad everyone loved it it was kind of
different we don't usually do like
sit-down interviews but I thought it was
like we took a chance and I'm glad we
did yeah I'm glad we did too and you did
an amazing job and I'm glad everyone
liked it and got so much out of it got
so much out of it and you know it's like
kind of like a busy couple of weeks
because we don't usually do guests but
we have another guest interview that I
recorded in L.A that's what happens when
turd goes to La it's so true the turd
hits the coast Los Angeles turd on
Thursday we have another interview if
you're on patreon you already know about
it it's going to be a really good one
um it's not the whole episode like last
time it's much shorter we'll have a
regular episode and then just the
interview at the end
um but I think you guys are gonna love
that one too so it's good stuff
fantastic fantastic stuff fantastic
fantastic stuff
yeah so other than that it was a pretty
quiet weekend over here I've been
reading the book for the redheads the
Magnificent lives of Marjorie post
amazing book episode drops Thursday we
record tomorrow it's not too late to
join everyone's loving this book amazing
fascinating woman that you've never
heard of but like you absolutely need to
like she's an heiress like one at one
point probably like the richest woman in
America and then like to see what she
did about that is pretty fascinating hmm
um I was actually so I went to the
Eagles game yesterday and I was at like
a family tailgate with a bunch of the
Wags I spoke to them they like being
called Wags so they didn't mind
um and I was talking to one of the Wags
moms and she was like I love she was
asking me about podcasting she's like I
like to read I listen to some reading
podcasts and I was like you should check
out trbc and I was explaining it's like
redheads but spelled read because my
sister has red hair she was like that is
just darling like she loved it
and you told her like what we do yep I
was like different girls different
perspectives different books a common
love of reading a book a month a book a
month but um that was just the beginning
to my day so yesterday obviously if
you're following football not an ideal
outcome for a couple of Niner girls but
um
so I went to the game
major shout out to Annie whose family
owns top crop which is like one of the
largest and oldest family-owned farms in
I think all of Pennsylvania and they
have had this you know suite at Lincoln
field for like years and years their
grandparents like it was like just
listening it was like it was actually
amazing and they were so cool and so
nice and like they were so generous to
host us and that's so nice and so
incidentally today's episode is brought
to you by top crop it's not but you
should check them out for all your
produce needs
um it was amazing they were like so nice
and they were just like these like they
were just like so like Jersey Italian
family like it was really it was really
awesome
um and so we had great seats and I was
feeling good you know
but before the game even started I just
want to say like
it is not even remotely possible for any
team to do a game
in Philly especially when the stakes are
super high and win like the energy like
I've been to a few football games in my
life and they're always like you know
the fans are great and they have all
these songs Philly was on another level
they have like all these chants and hand
motions and fireworks like it was on
crack it was just insane and the second
I sat down I was like it's gonna be so
hard like energy wise for a team to win
this game like the fan the fandom is the
way that it is for a reason like it's
crazy
so the home corn Advantage was real yeah
and I think like home court advantage is
definitely a thing but I think in Philly
it's on another level like the fans like
they were so engaged like whenever it
was their offense silence whenever it
was their defense crazy like and it
didn't weaned throughout the night like
people didn't lose energy it was it was
almost unfair like that's how much of an
impact I think the energy was having on
the field
interesting but a few things happened I
I don't know that it was the energy
because I was watching the game and by
the way I was not watching when Brock
got injured so you can't blame that on
me yeah but first I started watching the
game when it started and Philly scored a
touchdown and I was like okay I'm gonna
just go into the other room because I'm
you know bad luck and then I came back
out and it was 7-7 Christian has scored
amazing stuff Chris oh did you see
Christians by the way Christian was like
I'm so [__] done with this like
everyone is being dumb and he was just
like I decided I'm taking the ball and
running with it there was like 15 people
around him and nobody could touch him
like he's just I just decided I'm
scoring a touchdown right now and he
just did it it was actually really
impressive so at some point while I was
7-7 before I came back Brock got injured
yeah so then I started watching with
Brock was already injured and the 49ers
started stinking up the joint yeah not
only were the 49ers stinky the Eagles
were really really tight yeah like I
didn't realize they were a good team no
they're very good they're very good they
have what it takes yeah and I just want
to say one thing about the final score
which was like seven to 31 and it's not
I mean it's unfortunate that their
quarterback
and who's already like the second string
right got out they go on to third string
like they stand no chance no chance but
the defense LED in 31 points that has
nothing to do with Brock being on the
field no like I understand why the score
never went above seven for the 49ers but
like
no it was a total excuse for the defense
it was a cross
it was a nationwide failure like
everyone was thinking it up like now you
can't just I completely agree so I hope
that brings everyone Solace because
honestly if it was just the fact that
Brock was out like that would be so
frustrating like you know we are so
close and then the elbow went but I
think everybody contributed to them I
think we all stunk it up and then after
the third string quarterback no no but
they went to Fourth string
and then they just started tossing the
ball around like they were the Little
Giant strings no Brody Brady what's his
name Brock Brock
Claudia I know he came in and didn't
throw and he just kept tossing it they
ran the annexation of Puerto Rico they
did
excuse me you don't know that movie
Little Giants
Little Rascals
no the football movie about the kids and
they run the annexation of Puerto Rico
where they just keep tossing it and they
make it down the field no by the way I
have no idea what that means okay real
ones will know no that was a good joke
like I feel like if you get it like you
get it if you get it like I'm I'm the
funniest girl yeah well he couldn't
throw so he was just doing little tosses
like right right but I really wanted
them to put in like their fourth string
quarterback which you said was going to
be Kyle juice check but like on ESPN
they told us it was going to be
Christian McCaffrey and I feel like
either one of them would have been
really good like these guys like play
football yeah they put they play
football for fun like they can throw the
ball no I agree like they want it so bad
like you know Christian wants to win
like they have like a lot riding on it
like I agree they should have tried
something Christian and Kyle are so like
enmeshed in the game plans like I think
more so than the third string
quarterback who probably nobody ever
thought was gonna no and Ben was telling
me have to play he's been in the league
for 15 years like as as a scrub the boys
were telling me and you know what like
he could have really made a moment you
know like Brock Brock was relatively
unknown until Jimmy Garoppolo got
injured and you know what Brock made the
most of that moment Josh Johnson could
have been a hero and instead he's just
stinking it up
yeah I would have liked to see like
Christian or Kyle play quarterback
because I knew she would have had fun
playing and just like playing with their
teammates throwing the ball you know
different like what they were doing
wasn't working so try something
different yeah it was painful and you
know like I didn't want to be like
outwardly cheering for the 49ers one
because I don't want to disrespect the
family who invited me and they were huge
Eagles fans like there were Tears like
it was I was a Taylor Donahue and her
sisters they were literally not okay
like this was such a big deal so I
didn't want to be like annoying and then
I just started getting depressed I was
just like this sucks I'm depressed
and
yeah
but to bring it to a positive note I
then the second game was the Bengals
versus the Chiefs and I was like if the
Bengals win and it's Bengals versus
Eagles like I'm literally not watching I
have no
skin in this race oh that's so funny I
feel the other way like I don't really
like Kansas City like we have Patrick
Mahomes and we have Travis Kelsey and
now
why we're interested in the brother Bowl
lvi III whatever it's brother V brother
Jason Kelsey I'm the e-girls versus
Travis Kelsey I'm the Chiefs who are the
parents rooting for Jackie it's brother
burst brother
but more importantly it's podcasterverse
podcaster they have a podcast together
hit the brothers
the Brethren the Brethren have a podcast
together and actually a few weeks ago
they did an episode about catching
Kelsey and Travis was really honest he
said honestly I had no money I like ran
through every dollar I made in my rookie
like career I was just like excited to
be making money and they offered it to
me and I needed the money
oh my God one I'm gonna go listen to
that episode
two I cannot believe that the Kelsey
Brethren are podcasters what's their
podcast called catching Kelsey's it
should be no it's called like you know
off the field sideline I don't know some
[__] like that oh it's totally called
off the field you know what I mean like
uh
run the ball I want oh New Heights with
Jason and Travis Kelsey did I lie
oh my God are they gonna do an episode
of like leading up to the Super Bowl it
would be good for the Raiders yes it
would be good for Ratings it would be
I'm listening to the show now oh my God
I didn't realize oh I think that's a
cool angle for the Super Bowl and now
I'm invested once more it's a cool angle
for the Super Bowl Theo just got back
from his walk so if you hear a Yelp it's
Theo yeah we did hey no do not need my
Fiber One bar [__] that's mommy's
breakfast come here
um so now like who would you think
you're rooting for in the Super Bowl
I'm still rooting for Kansas City
I just have like no actually I mean a
little part of me is now
Eagles fill like uh
sympatheticles fan because the Wags that
I met over FaceTime yesterday were so
lovely yeah so we got to pre-game with a
bunch of Wags and they were like can we
please see pictures of Harry and I was
like of course you can and then they
were like what's Jackie doing like where
are you some Jackie here what is Jackie
like and I was like let's just FaceTime
her and they got to see this house Frau
in her bed looking a mess but they were
really sweet they were and you know what
they like want or support so badly I
will say though you know I was really
nervous about going to Philly as an
Eagles fan I mean as a Niners fan
Freudian slip I was completely fine like
drama for what but I was wearing an
Eagles hat so like I was trying to blend
in and I was with like six people like
decked out in Eagles gear
um I was fine but I do I did feel as
though you know if I were dressed
differently I would not have been fine
you know yeah yeah
yeah so you protected yourself but you
weren't being overly dramatic I'm
protecting myself I'm doing what's best
for me and my family yeah
yeah but you were unscrupled 100 100 and
of course I felt like if I wasn't there
the Niners wouldn't have lost you know
of course I felt like if I wasn't
invested in watching because of course I
didn't watch the second game but like
you know this small piece of me wanted
the Chiefs to win and they won handily
except I think it came down to a kick
it was a good game it was 20 to 23 like
that's what we should be getting not 30
to 7 a blowout oh and the worst part the
real worst part was like after in like
the third and fourth quarter when it was
very clear there was no coming back they
had no game plan they were losing all
the the Niners like we're being babies
like they were starting fights they were
getting penalties one of them got thrown
out like that one of them like shoved a
guy as he was stepping out of bounds
it's like he's on his way there anyway
that was not okay like that's what
losers do and you know what like that
was disappointing when that fight broke
out and one of the Niners players like
literally picked up this little this
little eagle and threw him to the ground
like that's not cool to do that when
you're losing that is just being a big
sword loser and it makes you look like a
loser I'm sorry it's not cool yeah well
you know what they hadn't lost in a
while so they forgot what it felt like a
hundred percent because they were
winning winning yep hundred percent
I'm glad I went I'm glad I went you are
yeah I had a good time like I really the
tailgate was like so fun and then once
the game started like my team was losing
and I was like this sucks but I like the
p i met such nice people yesterday I had
a good time it was a long day you know I
left my house at 10 30 and I got back at
10 30. I'm not used to being out of bed
that long on a Sunday
um but I got I also got 10 000 steps
like it was a good day
interest on so who are you rooting for
in the Super Bowl
it's so hard again when you truly don't
care about either teams find something
to care about well I care because like
I'm I was like annoyed at Philly
yesterday so I don't want them to win
now that's also that's usually what
happens it's like the team that beat
your team you can't root for I'm holding
a grudge
cheaps it is and you know what I'm gonna
support my fellow tick tocker Jackson
yes
Austin
no Jackson
who's Austin Austin is that singer he's
a little guy that little singer Jackson
I'm not okay I really thought Jackson
was the quarterback for a second like
Austin's the brother Patrick always
think that you always think that Patrick
to end I've been to Kansas City two
three times it's a fabulous town like
it's so underrated I really liked it
both times I went the only thing is like
I feel like there are actually a lot of
eagles celebrity fans who are like die
hard Bradley Cooper was at the game
where was at the game Miles Teller loves
the Eagles and who are the celebrity
Kansas City fans girl there are none
there's got to be like some because then
when I was on my Instagram last night
like then I saw in my stories like oh
all these people that I follow are
Eagles fans it makes sense they're like
from Philly or whatever
um like like I don't know if I know any
Kansas City fans which is why I have to
be the Kansas City fan I wish to see in
the world but I bet there are I bet
there are
yeah but I'm going with Kansas City me
too
I feel like the eagles are going to win
though they were looking really good I
know but it's like so easy to look good
against a team that's stinking it up
they were looking good before Brock got
hurt
I don't know
and then they were it was just like they
were sharp there were some crazy things
happening no it was it was very it was
good execution it really was it was so I
think they have what it takes
I think they have what it takes too but
you know you never count out the
Countess Patrick Mahomes is like the
goat for a reason yeah they're
everyone's the goat right Tom Brady's
the goat Aaron Rodgers is the goat no
Tom Brady was the goat Aaron Rodgers is
like not the goat everyone they call the
goat I just want to say that for sure
Patrick Mahomes like signed like the
biggest contract in NFL history like
there's there's something so did Russell
Wilson yeah and he was the go-to he
doesn't play anymore there can be a
million ghosts yes sir can yes there can
and different fields like I met you know
I heard actually I met Lane Johnson's
girlfriend and I found out via his
girlfriend that Lane Johnson is a
toaster and islane Johnson the best
player in the league no is he the best
at his position he's the goat offensive
tackle I want to say yeah you could be
the goat at different positions okay
because Christian McCaffrey's to go
right totally
Kyle's a goat
s Kyle's to go
I was in this suite and I had um like
these amazing fancy binoculars and my
God it was so clear I literally could
see more clear than the TV I was
literally not being a freak but like I
just wanted to see what was going on in
the 49ers bench like was there you know
depression sadness and I was well I
didn't even watch a game I literally sat
with the binoculars on looking at like
the facials Kyle
and George and like Brock like sitting
on this bench with their big coats like
being depressed I'm like you guys
it's never too late first of all their
energy like come on turn around
they should have sent you in there the
locker room for half time I would have
[__] [__] up I would have [__] [__]
up
whatever speech was given at halftime of
the last game yeah remember things
weren't going well where was that speech
maker and where was that speech
yesterday because sometimes somebody
just needs to be told like they're
acting like a loser
no no but you don't want to like sink
them deeper into their hole you have to
like you have to pump them up no but
it's like really you want to be a loser
okay you shame them that sounds firing
I'm not inspired really I think shame is
a very inspirational tool
I think it can be motivating but you
wanna you it has to walk the right line
the sad thing is that now I'm not going
to the Super Bowl unless you know
somebody wants to take me but I was
going to go like you know for the Niners
and like be a good fan so now I actually
really don't care like my boyfriend Joe
Burrows out my boyfriend Kyle you just
check us out like I don't really care
Patrick Mahomes are you okay
no no I'm not okay I knew that like I
literally knew it I just like I was
thinking stupid it hurts versus Mahomes
my hearts
hurts he was good so cute
they said hurts so good that's what the
fan sign said no everyone loved him it
was great they greased the polls
whatever can we move on like I'm already
I'm already in next season you know sure
well the Super Bowl is in two weeks and
that's what we got we got Eagles versus
Chiefs I think it's like such a meh
match up anyone else like I agree
so it was last year's
what was that Rams and lar versus the
Bengals what's lar LA Rams oh no that's
fabulous to me because there was like
Matthew Stafford like there was like
glamorous elements like I don't know
Patrick Mahomes is like
you know holding his family together by
a thread hoping they don't embarrass him
again and the other team I don't know
I'm just like not into the Eagles I saw
they don't have like any stars I looked
inside the belly of the Beast and I was
like you know I just think the Rams are
a flash in the pan I mean I completely
agree so irrelevant they didn't even
make the playoffs no like they're they
they're just like
what's the word they're not like a
franchise that's like a real franchise
they're like unscrupled kind of I said
it I'm gonna piss so many people off no
you know me I love they just like Bounce
from City to City yeah they're like
untethered yeah and that's like I can
respect the Eagles because they have
yeah
and their city has pride in them yeah
Roots there are new teams that like
untethered rootless the Chargers are not
charging on my iPad and the Raiders no
you're so right they're so untethered
can't relate couldn't be me
no like I was literally in a suite with
like a family who's owned this suite for
50 years like that's Roots that's being
tethered that's Scruples yeah could uh
the LA Ram stadium has been built for
five days yeah it's like oh there's a
new stadium being built in Las Vegas
where this chairs shake when there's a
tackle let's go there yeah no I'd rather
go to where there's history
Hershey
um
sets of football stuff you needed to
know if you skipped through that you can
tune back in now if you skip through
that you're lost you're missing out
girly you know I watched Top Gun this
weekend too oh
and it was really it was so good like
and I understand like we don't get
movies that are real movies anymore and
so I really enjoyed it and of course it
was so hyped up but I thought that the
way I didn't even watch the first one
but like I could like the storyline was
so full circle I felt like Tom Cruise
was like doing the most you know it was
like this like old leathery man being
the star I understand and the love story
between him and Jennifer Connelly like
vomit took everything in me not to fast
forward vomit
um I didn't like that my one of my
favorite people on Earth Glenn Powell
was a villainous character but he came
down to the end but then he saved the
day because it's like that's not the
John Glenn I know no no John Glenn
wouldn't ever no I agree I ended up I
left the theater with like a smile on my
face as it pertained to Glenn Powell
yeah the the dancing on the beach scene
what I just did was longer than what we
saw yeah no it was hella exaggerated on
social media like what that was unfair
like not you giving a movie review for a
movie that came out a year ago like no
but you know what I waited
it's worth the wait it was it's a great
film I actually got started on our Oscar
list because I saw the menu on Friday
night with um Anya Taylor Joy it was
fine it was good it was fine it was cute
as fresh like is it gonna win anything
no does it deserve to no was Anya even
like good no did the ending like make no
[__] sense yeah it made no
sense
um it's fine though it was like a good
way to spend the night you know did you
see this Oscars drama it's not a story
but someone who was nominated for best
actress when I read her name like we I
mean so many of the actress actors and
actresses like we've never heard of so
it wasn't that alarming but like I never
heard of the person or the movie and now
people are saying like the movie only
grows twenty seven thousand dollars and
they're saying there's like corruption
that this was nominated like you know
back channeling because this person does
not deserve to be nominated and the
other argument is like it doesn't need
to be a blockbuster to be nominated I'm
sorry it needs to earn there needs to be
a threshold of money that needs to earn
otherwise I could film Why Can't This Be
nominated for an office
we could do 27 000 views yeah we could
and by the way twenty thousand seven
thousand dollars earned like divided by
the price of a movie ticket yeah that's
that's very few tickets sold I need to
look into that I don't know how I feel
because like just because the movie
didn't make as much money doesn't mean
the performance isn't technically the
best of the five you know but like how
did you guys even find this movie that's
the question like where what gutter did
you pick this movie out of and the only
like back channeling I didn't
investigate into this but people are
saying like the actress and her team
like they really emailed hard and like
called and like that's not a crime okay
so like nobody nobody else dating for
yourself is not a crime and by the way
everybody does that
but is it a little more nefarious
no you're there's something there uh I I
want to look into this yeah I'm gonna
launch an investigation I thought that
was interesting it is
and so I guess now without further
here are the best type stories that you
need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
Branch Basics non-toxic hypoallergenic
free of fragrance hormone disruptors and
harmful preservatives they're baby and
pets safe they're clean and cost
effective it's Branch Basics we only
want the safest and best products that
actually work around our pets and our
babies because only the best
and stress and little rodini ain't that
really the best for these boys so Branch
Basics one concentrate is a product that
can be used for everything it makes
laundry detergent hand soap dish soap
all-purpose cleaner bathroom floor
cleaner it can replace every single
cleaning product in your home and Branch
Basics offers the refill model so once
you run out the only thing you need to
repurchase is the concentrate and the
oxygen boost so in 2023 I feel like we
all need to be more responsible about
what we're bringing into our houses I
feel like once you have a kid like it
really puts into perspective like you're
just spraying chemicals around Harry's
bathroom in his tub like no no
is super pet and baby safe again it has
no fragrance no hormone disruptors no
harmful preservatives it's super clean
and then with the refill model it's very
cost effective and we of course have a
code for you guys um the starter kit
that'll get you started you could
literally toss out all the products
under your sink in your bathroom just
for this one concentrate that will turn
into like five or six products so get 15
off the starter kit when you use code
the toast at branchbasics.com we
recommend the premium starter kit for
all your cleaning needs that's what
Jackie and I both have it freed up so
much space beneath my cabinets like I
know you live in a house but just
another benefit of this company is the
more space you have under your sink so I
don't know if you saw the announcement
that I made on Instagram this weekend
that I am clean and going clean and
getting cleaner and Branch Basics is one
of the products that made that so easy I
said so many of the toe sponsors are
clean Brands and I don't have to like go
and seek them out Branch Basics is that
brand for all of your cleaning needs
again that's code the toast for 15 off
branchbasics.com today's episode is also
brought to you by Legacy box I think of
all the sponsors this is the one I get
reached out to the most like what was
the code for that company what was that
company called listen up Legacy box
think of all the time and money your
family invests in capturing capturing
family vacations football games
birthdays weddings over the years
recording a lifetime of memories was a
commitment and camcorders can cost
thousands of dollars tapes are expensive
and cameras were back in the day
requiring film and development so now
you have a box of stuff and you have
memories you cannot access until now
thanks to Legacy box so Legacy box
exists to preserve your family's
recorded moments digitally ensuring that
they're safe forever so if you have a
box of VHS we did it years ago it was
the best thing we ever did we grew up in
the VHS era we had boxes in storage of
just like moments we had no idea what
was on there for years we tried like
different things like this VHS converter
none of it worked and it was so
expensive and hard Legacy box sends you
packaging they send you a a label throw
all your camcorders your tapes your
cassettes whatever you got throw it in
the box and they will digitize it for
you buy by hand it's all done in America
it's super safe and it's just the best
way to preserve your family's memories
you can reclaim Your Glory Days makes a
great gift for someone or just for
yourself it's like something you've been
putting off you owe it to your family to
safeguard your memories don't let your
photos continue to fade become your
family's hero and the favorite Child
save them before it's too late when you
buy a legacy box today that's
legacybox.com toast to shop this
exclusive offer legacybox.com
t-o-a-s-t legacybox.com toast
thank you mclared you're welcome our
first story big news that came out uh on
Friday I think Blake Lively and Justin
baldoni will star in it ends with us
Justin baldoni is also directing and
Sony Wayfarer Studios adaption I don't
know what that means Blake Lively and
Justin baldoni are attached to star in
the film adaptation of Colleen Hoover's
best-selling novel it ends with us which
is in development with Wayfarer Studios
and Sony Pictures baldoni is also set to
direct with Christy Hall adapting the
script Alex Sachs will produce for the
sax Pixar company along with Jamie Heath
who will produce on behalf of Wayfair
Studios Lively and Hoover are also
executive producing along with a bunch
of other people a lot of cooks in the
kitchen on this movie so it is
pretty certain that Blake Lively will be
playing Lily who is our main character
and Justin baldoni will be playing Atlas
yeah not him like directing and giving
himself the best part so there's not
been confirmative confirmation but Blake
Lively did post uh Instagram story with
darker hair that's like brownish reddish
Auburn with the song playing Lily my one
and only which means it was a
confirmation okay except like until she
posted that sorry honestly I'm sorry no
it's confirmed Colleen Hoover the this
news broke because Colleen Hoover made a
tick tock and told everyone right until
Colleen Tick Tock I thought maybe she
would be playing like she would be
involved in executive producing and like
playing ryle's sister because this is a
miscast okay this is such a flop and I'm
I'll preserve judgment like I will see
the movie with open mind but first of
all I read the book
um I love the book the characters are
much younger than both of these two it's
it's supposed to be this like really
young girl who finds herself in like a
shitty [__] situation and doesn't
know what to do and like when you see
Blake Lively she's older she's more
mature like
someone of that age would handle the
situation that Lily's put in very
differently than someone who's actually
Lily's age I hate this
um I also hate the Justin baldoni part
of it because let me tell you why uh I
don't know Justin baldoni I know people
like die for him from like the Gina
Rodriguez show Jane the Virgin I don't
know this man I kind of I don't know why
like I just get thirsty vibes from him I
cannot explain like I know nothing about
you want to know why why because he has
a podcast
oh
that's his podcast which was nominated
for a Webby
jealous
um I just like I I cannot stress how
much I hate this and people on Tick Tock
have been doing like here's who I would
have cast doing so oh my gosh good jobs
there this was so ripe for an amazing
casting not only is Lily such a great
character it's such a great story it's a
young story so we could have a young
actress we could have someone we don't
know a young Starlet introduced to
someone like I hate to be ageless but
these two are too old for not ages to
say how old is Blake Lively please
Google that for me it's not Aegis to say
somebody who's I think she's I'm gonna
say like 38.
yes also Lily had just graduated college
so she's like 22 and Blake Lively's 35.
she's too old I'm sorry that's not being
Aegis it's just facts
yeah I hate this casting and it's like
when we go to the younger scenes of when
she knows Atlas in high school like are
they gonna get a different actress oh
you're not gonna have me oh watching
Blake Lively play a high school so are
you I had seen people casting like their
dream roles Sadie sink for a young Lily
of course was perfection
um
to me this just sucks like to me it's
just so obvious to go with like Blake
Lively and like her name is you know
like Lively everyone knows her she's
it's just so I don't know so uninspired
and I love her this is nothing against
her just this like sucks it is
uninspired missed opportunity even
though I'm sure Colleen is over the moon
with the casting because like this gives
so many eyeballs to her movie but like
this book sold already has copies like
it's gonna be a big success also people
are upset because Lily is a redhead yeah
and we don't have a natural redhead in
the role no that's true and you know in
the age where like we don't you know no
more skinny people playing fat people
straight people playing gay people where
do the redheads fall into that people
playing hetero people yeah
it begs the question an unnatural Reddit
though personally if you want my opinion
as a redhead that part doesn't bother me
especially since she's dyeing her hair
red it's like you know she's wearing the
fat suit yay there will still be the fat
character no it's still being a redhead
it's literally fine
well I'm just saying no I'm saying I
agree with you yeah but that's because
that's been our thinking like every time
this conversation comes up
um I don't know I just like the sucks
like it really [__] sucks
yeah and who's gonna play Royal now and
Ryle is older like Clint Eastwood yeah
like not to like this just sucks
you heard it here first Clint Eastwood
cast and Colleen Hoover's adaptation
of it ends with us you know who should
play Ryle
who Ryan Reynolds
literally I think a lot of people just
assumed that Justin baldoni would be
playing Ryle like because he was
involved in the project and he kind of
like looks like the described
character like in the book does he to me
he looks like Atlas no to me he looks
like Ryan in this picture that they're
showing well the hair
yeah because ryle's like I think I I
imagined him as as Ryle
but he's playing Atlas yeah
and to me I see Atlas as like this I
can't I can't explain like this pajam
you know yeah
I don't know I just like
I want to go home like I hate this yeah
I just feel like this movie could have
been you know like Miley and Liam in the
last song like yes bring us like young
love even they don't even have to be
unknowns and instead we got this
like I don't
yeah oh that guy from age of Adeline
would be good too you know I think of
him a little bit as like a rile
um I just feel like and it's gonna be a
hot take and maybe you know
maybe I'm gonna get hate for it and I
love her I just feel like every movie
Blake Lively does is not a real movie I
can't explain it like her last couple of
movies are like a simple favor which
like wasn't real do you know what I mean
it's like not a real movie yeah that one
where she like lives on a rock and
there's a shark around her not real yeah
age of Adeline which was good but it's
like a fake movie like nobody actually
saw it do you know what I mean yeah no I
like have a really crazy take what like
it's really like hot I can't I can't
wait to hear it
she seems so nice though I love her
Taylor's best friend I love her like I
love her she's so beautiful I think
she's an amazing mom she's a great
business woman like non-alcoholic drinks
like she I really really love her and
like she's the most beautiful woman in
the world so I think she could handle
this when I say it acting isn't for her
she's a good actress like she ruined
Serena vanderwood so you know what I
agree I think we're all like so blinded
by we're blinded by her beauty and her
Fame and like her family and it's
perfect and Ryan like we're blinded into
thinking she's like she's A-list in
terms of like Fame but not in terms of
talent yeah you know what I wouldn't
call her that call I wouldn't call her
wickedly talented no you know what
I agree
but she's so beautiful like why wouldn't
you want to watch her even if she's like
screwing up no I know and it's like
she kind of like has gotten really far
in Hollywood for like not being good but
because she's so beautiful and like
she's naturally this beautiful and like
there are a lot of pretty and beautiful
people in Hollywood but like she's
exceptional exceptional looking and
since she's young like since Sisterhood
of the Traveling Pants and like such a
good film and like she what she was like
16 then and now she's 35 and like she's
just as beautiful like we deserve to see
her all the time but so true
yeah no I I feel that called like
Jessica that's my call that's a good
call it's a good call and I feel bad you
could try Sears but you know what she'll
be okay she'll be fine she's doing fine
I just I'm like I'm still gonna see the
movie I'm just like not even remotely
looking forward to it
yeah
yeah and I'm really curious if they're
gonna do like young youngins I hope they
do I hope they do that would give us
like a little bit of that what we're
looking for in terms of like fresh new
faces and the like the LA the back end
like the
past portions of the book are so good
and they're germane to the store Beyond
they have to do half and half yeah the
book if you've never read it flops
between like this present day couple and
the couple when they met in high school
and both parts are equally important to
understand one another and there's like
a lot of drama that happens in the past
and it's not just like one flashback
it's half the book right and now we need
to get a young actress who looks like
Blake Lively doesn't not like lily as I
imagine her right
stinks yeah so there you go
are you ready for our next story
yeah
some surprising estate drama surrounding
the Presleys Priscilla Presley has
contested Lisa Marie Presley's will she
claims there's an invalid signature so
let me get through the deets but
Priscilla Presley has contested the
authenticity and validity of Lisa Marie
Presley's will the businesswoman filed
documents in La Superior Court on
Thursday challenging a purported 2016
Amendment to the will which ousted her
as trustee so in the earlier version of
the will Priscilla was a trustee and
then there's this 2016 amendment that
ousted her and it put Riley and Benjamin
Priscilla's to
Lisa Marie's two children as the
trustees but Benjamin has since passed
away the amendment allegedly removed
Lisa Marie's former business manager
Barry Siegel along with Priscilla from
the trust leaving Riley now the sole
trustee after her brother died by
suicide in 2020. in the court filing
Priscilla claimed she and Siegel were
first named co-trustees in January 1993
when Lisa Marie executed a revocable
living trust which she amended and
completely restated on January 27 2010
however when she died in January she
claims Priscilla claims she found a new
Amendment which was dated from March
2016. Priscilla alleges in the docs that
her daughter's signature on the 2016
document quote appears inconsistent with
her usual and customary signature
further arguing that Lisa Marie's name
had even been spelled wrong
she also claimed that the document was
never notarized and had not been
delivered to her during the summary's
lifetime as laid out in the terms of the
2010 trust oh that's weird Priscilla
went on to note that she believes Barry
Siegel has already or will soon resign
as co-trustee of the trust it's worth
noting that Lisa Marie and that Barry
Siegel Finance guy like they have a PO
long legal battle he like left her with
fourteen thousand dollars and a ton of
bills and like took advantage of her oh
my God Everyone is always taking
advantage of the Presley's the Presleys
yeah
um this is so shady like an unnotarized
misspelled yeah that's weird
it is weird it's not weird that she took
off Barry Siegel but it would be weird
that she removed Priscilla who was at
one point her executor and if she wasn't
weird no but if she was going to switch
her children to have told Priscilla that
yeah but I guess at one point like
you're not supposed to you're outlive
your daughter so I think you know the
thinking was moving it from my mother to
my children because you know
it should go you know my mother dying
and then me and then my children right
so I mean it's I like I feel like it has
to actually be really that crazy if
Priscilla's like fighting this legally
because otherwise it just means that
Riley's the executor and like that's her
granddaughter right that's no problem I
also feel like it should be relatively
easy to figure out if this like document
is fraudulent and forged yeah and it's
like yeah if it was then like who
fortunate also like who would do such a
thing with the express
interest of like Riley and Benjamin
right right you know it's not like so
and so put his name in there
no there's something a little weird here
there's something a little weird here I
think so too
so wait and say that was surprising
especially like so soon after yeah it's
surpassing like she was playing last
week when like like obviously that's the
thing about death is like there's a lot
of paperwork so you're trying to grieve
and then there's like a million things
yeah so if you see like a funky
signature and big changes were made ask
questions you got to ask some questions
but also she like is filing she's filing
she's filing Tings
the Tings have been filed
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
modern fertility for a lot of us this is
the start of the New Year feels like the
right time to schedule a doctor's
appointment check in with where where
you're at health-wise but what about
your reproductive Health we've always
been big fans of planning ahead you know
scheduling trips months in advance
plotting out our next career move
figuring out what we're doing for dinner
while we're still eating breakfast but
we've never thought much about planning
for kids did you know that one out of
eight couples struggle with infertility
which is a staggering statistic that
most people generally don't know or
aren't ready to talk about
that's why modern fertility was created
it's an easy and affordable way to test
your fertility hormones at home with a
simple finger prick you'll mail it in
with a prepaid label and you'll get your
personalized results within six days
you'll get an insight into your hormone
levels like your ovarian reserve AKA if
you have more or fewer eggs than your
average the average woman your age and
you'll get insights into other important
factors that can impact your fertility
the results will go deep into what every
hormone means and you can also download
the results to view with your doctor for
next steps keep in mind the traditional
hormone testing at a fertility clinic
can cost over 600 but modern fertility
tests the same general set of hormones
and it only cost 179 dollars and we've
got a code because if you go to
modernfertility.com toast you'll get an
additional 20 off your test and you can
get reimbursed for the test through your
FSA or your HSA
right now modern fertility is offering
ever listeners 20 off the test when you
go to modernfertility.com toast that
means your test will cost 159 which is
just a fraction of what it would cost at
a fertility clinic get 20 off your
fertility test at modernfertility.com
toast that's modernfertility.com
toast today's episode is also sponsored
by Squarespace Squarespace is everything
to sell anything they have tools that
you need to get your business off the
ground including e-commerce templates
inventory management a simple checkout
process and secure payments whatever you
sell Squarespace has merchandising
features to make your products look
their best online so if this year you
want to get into like a side hustle or
you work in e-commerce and you don't
have a ton of experience building
websites Squarespace is an amazing place
to start I have built many websites over
my years on the internet and I can tell
you Squarespace is the easiest to do it
because I think a lot of people are very
intimidated by building a website
especially if you don't have a
background in like software engineering
or design
um and you don't need to Squarespace can
get you up and running with like a
really professional looking website that
you can design line so easily their
templates are really easy to use and you
don't need to have like a computer
science background to get it done they
also um just make e-commerce really easy
they uh have insight to your analytics
with their traffic overview you can see
how your visits unique visitors and Page
views are trending you can get insight
into the top traffic Source the products
to device types browsers operating
systems it's really great and also the
great part about Squarespace is that you
own all the content that you put on the
platform they offer a one-click data
portability so if you've been you know
thinking about getting into a side
hustle a side business or you work in
e-commerce and you want to revamp your
website check out squarespace.com toast
and you'll get a free trial and when
you're ready to launch make sure to use
code toast to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain again
that's squarespace.com toast for a free
trial and then offer code toast to save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or a domain
thank you Claudia that's so wonderful
that you shared that with us you're
welcome
our next story an end to The Saga of Amy
roback and TJ Holmes they have been
fired exited at ABC ABC confirmed Friday
that quote distractions TJ Holmes and
Amy roback are officially out at the
network following their scandalous
Affair sources tell page six that the
deal between the network and their gma3
anchors turned lovers was signed
executed and done by Friday afternoon an
ABC spokesperson later confirmed the
news in a statement saying after several
productive conversations with Amy and TJ
about different options we all agreed
it's best for everyone that they move on
from ABC News we recognize their talent
and commitment over the years and are
thankful for their contributions also
then this weekend Amy and TJ were
spotted
um
yeah so they're still together that's
what's most important
um I feel like there's something we
don't know here because to be honest
like dating your co-worker is not a
fireable offense especially when you
work in media and there's been so much
press around this and people are like
kind of obsessed it's all good all
Rising Tides rise all shies you know so
I feel like they did an investigation
like found something else out like I
don't know I feel like I'm missing a
piece of information because I don't
really understand what these two did to
get let go well along the way I feel
like I saw some stories about how he had
had some other affairs with people that
he worked with like over the years not
while he's been with Amy
I think that they they made it seem like
that affected Amy and what how she felt
about him but they're still together so
maybe that's all nonsense
um I don't know like How Deeply these
claims were right but
um no I think that I think that ABC just
like totally like played this wrong and
read this wrong I think they thought you
know after a week like nobody really
cared anymore and I think they like
still felt like oh my God everybody's
talking about us everybody's like
talking about even TJ it's like no we're
not we're not I think firing them was
the complete wrong choice they're also
good anchors yep and that's hard to find
these days as we've seen you know
there's so much like turnover
and everyone's always looking for like
the new hose like these are good hosts
so I don't know what they'll do next I
think this is a mistake yeah maybe
there's more to the story but I just
think ABC looks stupid I agree and I'm
sure that they got paid out handsomely
and they you know signed a bunch of
stuff because honestly this is like if
it's just on the surface of what we know
it's definitely wrongful termination
like your personal life like it really
cannot I must say you know
signed something that they wouldn't date
anyone there's really nothing that we
know that's worth getting fired over so
I'm sure they got like a very generous
package and they don't have to work
yes but I don't think their package
would be like they don't have to work
for the rest of their lives no but like
for the foreseeable they could take a
break and go to La and be you know
stressing each other outside the
restaurant yes and that's just what they
did right so maybe they'll do a podcast
next like for sure I mean it's already
crowded so just join us Jump Right In
you could go on the Kelsey podcast you
could go on our podcast yeah we'd love
to talk to you we'd love to
about what really happened because like
this is a nothing Burger nothing oh my
God I love they found oh and they were
married before okay so they found love
and they're being punished they found
love
in an unexpected place in a hopeless
place don't we want to celebrate love
yeah they literally found love in a
hopeless place like the third fourth
hour of the GMA no one's watching that
and they have stuck by each other's
sides through this whole roller coaster
I probably at one point would have been
like honestly you're not we're not worth
the trouble no it's actually like a
beautiful love story
yeah I look forward to seeing the movie
about it starring Blake Lively 100 she
would do great
she was she would do great in this role
are you ready for our next story a
little more TV news
page six is reporting that Bravo has
lost interest in Roni Legacy as contract
talks stall over money I believe this
the real houses of New York City Legacy
show may not happen because of a dispute
about how much the cash should be paid
page success exclusively learned we're
told Bravo has hit pause on contract
negotiations with sources close to the
cast telling us the network is
lowballing them while production
insiders hope that they think that the
talent think they should make but the
cast of Friends made in their hate
meanwhile page six is told that the
network appears to have lost interest in
pursuing the Legacy Edition amid the
deadlock
so I believe this I believe that the
Legacy women want to get paid what like
at least what they were making at the
last paycheck that they got and for
Bravo like that's an expensive show when
they have you know a new show Rooney
regular where they're making their
starting salary entry level no and it's
a lot of money to pay women on a show
that sucked like the show we are at this
Crossroads because the show stunk right
you keep paying these ogs like Sonia
Luanne who've been on forever who won't
accept less than a million a season
probably more
to pay that for a show you have no idea
if it's even going to be successful like
No And for a show that when we last
spoke flopped it failed yeah like why
would you pay them those rates and I
also understand why for them like
they're not going to really get out of
bed maybe they'll accept like a little
bit less okay so you know we've been
humbled our show wasn't doing well but
like
they're not getting out of bed they're
not you know sharing their lives and
everything that's so personal to them
because those women really give it all
and like
they're not going to do that and you
know what this whole story just makes
Ramona look like a queen like Ramona she
said she bowed out some people didn't
believe her I actually kind of do she's
bad out she's not even involved she's
you know posting her real estate content
and she's not getting like dragged into
this and honestly I feel like that was a
really good call because I feel like the
show might not even see the light of day
yeah I I really agree there's all these
like headlines that Ramona is better
than ever happier than ever glad to be
done with Roni yeah I do believe that
especially if there's not going to be a
show anyway and like she looks like
the smartest one in the room yeah so my
mind immediately went to Ramona I could
so see these women being like it's
Legacy we've been on forever like I want
two million dollars like I could see
that I could see Bravo being like
weighing their options like this is dumb
by the way because I'm sure this show
will not even get picked up for a season
two
um so I I actually understand both
parties in The Crossroads and I honestly
I don't think they should do the show
yeah I could see like Luanne being like
you know I'm not doing I'm the Countess
but you know I'm a big star I'm not
doing this for more than
let's say a million dollars and then
that also makes people like Sonia and
the other ones being like well if
luanne's getting a million I want a
million I've been on longer you know
blah blah blah yeah so whether this is
true or not I don't know but I could see
it being entirely true
yeah and it's like there's almost like
no energy for it like
do they care no I don't think the lay
people care
it's just like die hard like corner of
the internet Bravo fans and I don't know
if that's enough to to make money for a
network it's not so I feel sorry for
them like yeah if if they don't get what
their you know their show but there are
so many now like opportunities ultimate
girls trip like throw them in there
Bravo Cod there's a way to be a Bravo
Liberty without having a show
now we just had that show on peacock
Traders or whatever they had like people
like from shots of sunset all different
reality shows that have been canceled
that are not still on and there's a way
to have a career as a reality star
without like having your own show yeah I
think that they would be better off you
know sending them on some of these
ultimate girls trips than giving them
their own show I agree
I agree are you ready for our fifth and
final story final story final story yes
I am
uh a little collaboration news that
never was that I actually found so
interesting Katy Perry reveals a huge
mistake in declining to work with Billy
eilish
video was posted by 102.7 KISS FM on
Friday Katy Perry was performing and she
told a group of fans during what
appeared to be an intimate gig about the
collaboration that could have come to
life she said Katy Perry said she
received an email from someone that said
hey check out this new artist I'd really
like us to work with her because she was
working for me she was working with
unsub records at the time Billy was
unknown she said it was a song called
ocean eyes and it was just a blonde girl
and I was like meh boring dead then she
admitted it was a big mistake huge
mistake passing up on the offer and said
don't let this hit the internet no but
you know what like no I completely
that's how the music industry works like
there are so many like pretty young
talented girls and there's really no
reason why one makes it over the other
you know no and the song Ocean eyes I
know it's like the biggest song in the
world it's never done much for me I love
it and if I heard it for the first time
I would have been like meh boring no
thanks
but there was no way for her to know I
think that this gig she was at or
whatever maybe it's not the same one but
you know she was like in Australia this
weekend at this like good day Australia
like charity it was like this big fancy
black tie event and the like the
honorees were Katy Perry and Miranda
Kerr and they like posted a million
photos together and I just felt like it
was so weird like because Miranda Kerr
was there with Evan Spiegel I don't know
if Orlando Bloom was there with Katie
but like Katie's husband father of a
child is Miranda Curtis ex and like
Miranda Kerr I just started following
her on Instagram because she follows me
and she's so premium and she's so
stunning and I saw like a million
pictures she like posted a thousand
times with Katy Perry I was like what is
going on in the House of Commons maybe
they all get along no I think that they
do I mean Miranda also moved on to
Miranda and Orlando have kids together
any oh that's a good call
then that makes sense as to how they
could be like so you know peaceful and
co-parently
okay she has
three kids
yeah one's a bloom okay Christopher
Blanchard so you know what that's really
nice that's really nice that they all
get along
yeah I mean it's nicer so happy and
moved on like Orlando and Katie are so
in love and of course Evan and Miranda
so it's easy to co-parent when you know
everyone ends up in a really happy you
know successful relationship with
somebody equally as Rich you know
yeah yeah when everybody lands on their
feet why can't we be happy for one
another it's nice
check out the pics no and they look so
cute and like they actually kind of look
like I could see like how that would be
like Orlando Bloom's type you know what
I mean yeah like if you just look they
have like kind of like the same face
okay I'm gonna go look at the big eyes
big you know what they have they have
ocean eyes
I do love hearing about like missed
opportunities like things celebrities
passed on that end up being I feel like
I'm watched weapons live Andy's always
asking like is it true you were supposed
to be Rose in Titanic and like I love I
love learning about that
um people's reaction to it is also
really funny
yeah and also sometimes it's like
someone auditioned for something they
would have loved to get it that's what
happens most of the time like yeah
but not that they passed on the
opportunity of a lifetime but also still
like what could Katy Perry have done on
Ocean eyes that like I know you know
she's still she's like a pop Global icon
so I don't know what working with Billy
eilish would have done for her except
maybe make her a lot of money
she's got a lot of money she'll be okay
she'll be fine do you think that they
look alike if they're looking at
pictures of them yeah they're both just
gorgeous yeah they just look like like
the same girl kind of
era
oh that's so cute she's kind of
everything of the sort like the more I
think about her I mean I could talk
about her marriage for a lifetime she
was on a skinny confidential podcast I
know because she has a brand makeup
brand Cora Cora Organics or something is
it is it clean it's very clean and she
was on the podcast talking about how
like it's so crazy what gets put into
our makeup and skincare products like
trying to say that's what I'm trying to
say
no wonder you're you're in your Miranda
era because we're the same so true and
I'm always in my Jackie O era
my Jackie era
um so those are the past five definitely
needed to know I'm really glad honestly
I was like annoyed when our episode came
out on Friday and we didn't have a
chance to talk about Blake Lively
because like I was [__] pissed like I
was like now I'm over it because like I
moved on with my life but like I was
like this [__] sucks
yeah I'm gonna move on with my life I'm
just not gonna be as excited as I once
was for the movie like maybe you know
it'll be like Top Gun where I see it
eight months too late
sorry and I I think that because I'm not
really excited about it like it's not
gonna be successful yeah no and I think
that they should kind of take a step
back and look and say Jackie O's not
excited maybe we should change things up
yeah maybe Blake Lively should play
ryle's sister
yeah I I want to find this Tick Tock
somebody cast the movie to Perfection I
think I know what it well it was like
Sadie sink plays young Lily
Abigail Cowan plays
older Lily
who's Abigail Cowan she's from
um Sabrina that he wouldn't know her
from oh that she was in Sabrina the
Teenage Witch but she's just a oh
gorgeous redhead people really wanted
the guy who plays um Conrad in the
Summer I Turned Pretty to play Young
Atlas and I totally saw that okay
um Lily Collins as ryle's sister yes
okay so he saw the same Tick Tock
married I think it was um Miles Teller
to be Marshall
because Marshall's like this Goofy I
kind of saw Marshall as like a really
young Jason Segel okay wait wait here I
think I have the tick tock you're
looking for
yeah I'm all brushed up on my talk
oh well really young Jason Siegel yeah
that's pretty
um he's too old now and I think Miles
Teller could could do a good job at like
a good Marshall like goofy curly hair
yeah and everybody wants Ryle to be Theo
James from White White Lotus yes this
one says do you see what I sent you
where'd you send it to me Sadie sink is
Young Lily yeah
Louis Patrick is Young Atlas no okay
that's what I that's Abigail Cowan I
found it okay okay look at the one that
I sent you though no I already saw that
one when I was just looking right now
because I Googled the same thing as you
so Conrad from Noah Centennial as
Marshall yeah that one stinks I don't
like that that casting that one went
viral this one went viral okay okay
Conrad as young Atlas adult Atlas Alex
pettifer I don't like that but that's
the only flaw in the let's give him
Blake Lively Sadie's sink young Lily of
course
Holland Roden as adult Lily do you know
hold on let me Google she's very
completely dated Zac Efron
I don't know if she's like one Holland
Roden
gorgeous yes she's familiar she has like
that face Theo James is Ryle
Miles Teller as Marshall
Lily Collins as Marshall's uh wife
Alyssa ryle's sister this is the best
one shout out to Katie Feeney on Tick
Tock for going viral with that
uh yeah that's good like the fact that
people on Tick Tock can like make a cast
come to life better than us movie studio
will just blow my mind in perpetuity
yeah and I do feel like Tick Tock should
have been able to weigh in a little bit
considering like they have some good
ideas this was the book of tick tock so
true so [__] true
I wonder how Colleen feels I mean I'm
sure she's mostly like so down but like
that could feel so much ownership over
her books it's like no I wrote them I I
think for us it's my vision but I think
for an author that's like the dream
oh yeah I mean what happened to her and
her books and like just the virality in
book talk and everything like is amazing
yeah
and I think any concept came along with
it or not even a blip up there for her
she just bought her mama house she's
fine
yeah
um so that's our show
that is it is correct yeah yeah ours oh
no I feel like some people thought it
was the Kelsey Brothers show but no but
it wasn't that's so similar that's new
heights
right is that the name of it I don't
know in the Heights I feel it I thought
it was I think it was new heights
hold on I already lost it Kelsey Bros
the Kelsey Brethren that's what should
be called 100 new heights is that what I
said are we okay
it's just it's a bad name that you
literally can't remember if you've tried
your life depended on it so this has
been a new episode of new heights thank
you so much for listening to new heights
the millennial Morning Show where we
deliver the pasta story so you need to
everybody through Friday on YouTube so
if you're watching this on YouTube
please don't forget to subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast everywhere
podcast can be found so at Spotify
iTunes public video I don't guess box
all the places
we are hope you guys have an enclave
Monday we'll see ya tomorrow
love you bye